[Music]
joining me today is the founder of the
Internet emergency and video games er
he's also a therapist coach author and
lecturer with many years of experience
in working with substance abuse and
addiction
Patrick Winston welcome to the Rubin
report thank you so much thanks for
having me
yeah well I'm really looking forward to
this conversation because so many of the
things that I talk about on this show
come back to the internet we you know we
talk about politics we talk about sex or
whatever it is that we're talking about
and somehow the Internet is right in the
middle of it right now we're connecting
over the Internet I watched your TED
talk about all this stuff on the
internet and you talked a lot about
Internet addiction so let's first start
there you at one time were an Internet
addict right well I used to play video
video games a lot so I was a pro gamer
loved first-person shooter spell games
so I played a lot in my days but it
becomes so rewarding because the games
that are MMO multi massively player
online the games that you actually go
online and play for me it was like a new
world just entered so I played a lot so
I played Counter Strike until three four
o'clock in the morning I had to wake up
you know like seven o'clock in the
morning to go to work and of course you
know your body can manage for a couple
of days a couple of weeks even months
but then again I came to a point where I
was totally exhausted and I had to you
know break out of it and my friends
wanted to help me so they made an
intervention and actually after that I
went to therapy myself I was so
interested in these areas so I wanted to
become a psycho therapist myself and
start helping people but in the
beginning I was doing many other things
like working with alcoholism and drug
abuse and those kind of areas but the
last five years I've been specialized in
technology the psychology of Technology
which is you know mobile phones what
they
nology does to us as well as video
videogames
yeah and in your TED talk you lay out
sort of how each of these things is kind
of changing us so I think when people
hear about video game addiction for
people that aren't gamers aren't in this
world at all I don't think they can
really understand how that can be
addictive you know they think of drugs
as addictive or they think of alcohol is
addictive but how is a video game
actually addictive what were you feeling
so it's 2:00 a.m. you've been playing
Counter Strike for six hours
what are you feeling at that point well
first of all I mean the word in itself
in the States and even in Europe we
can't call it addiction yet the depends
which country you're at if you're in
China or sand or in South Korea it is a
diagnostic you know disease that they
treated as a big problem but now in the
DSM the manual that the psychiatrists
are using now they're describing in
Chapter three that they're now doing you
know research if this is also coming
here in Europe and in the States so
basically what happens is you have to
look where it becomes consequences in
which areas in life like social areas
and physical areas and mental areas and
social areas could be that you are up
all night you don't want to go to school
you are isolating yourself you're eating
you know food only in your room all the
time you're having headaches you're
being depressed so these are the things
that they are trying to study and there
are a lot of things that are happening
in the brain the part of the brain that
we are calling the the reward center of
the brain that is the area which are
releasing dopamine the the hormone
dopamine in our bodies which is a
pleasure center which makes us feel good
and that's where we are coming back to
you know things that makes us feel good
and of course these things are very
normal to us so we have to you know
look at things that gives normal
releases of dopamine and things that are
giving extreme releases of dopamine yeah
how much of this do you think is related
to the online part these massive online
games that you mentioned versus just the
traditional game that you might play at
a console by yourself my audience knows
I used to be a big gamer but I'm talking
like old-school Nintendo and Sega
Genesis yeah recently just in the last
couple weeks my friend Colin got me a
ps4 and I haven't started the online
thing yet but I'm playing some shooters
and I play for literally 15 or 20
minutes I feel like I get it out of my
system and then I don't have to play for
the rest of the day and I'll you know
skip a couple days and then play again
but that I'm just playing locally with
myself or or co-op you know with one
other person what is it about the online
part of it actually the connecting with
other people that actually adds to the
addiction as well so basically the
difference is when it comes to online is
that the games are endless for one it's
endless and also today the the the games
that are created today are very
sophisticated when it comes to gaming
developers there are you know creating
very sophisticated ranking systems as
well as reward systems so basically what
we're seeing not in only in my treatment
center but all over the world it's
common things that often recurs and one
thing is the social aspect that it could
be other problems that is from the past
it could be you know bullying in school
or you know like their parents are
divorced and they're having a hard time
being in with their emotions so they go
to the virtual world which is much more
safer you know they can just play and go
into this tunnel site they don't have to
think about feelings and also like I
said it gives us the reward of
adrenaline and also the pleasure center
of dopamine so they go to these kind of
events and also the identity
aspects they are creating an identity of
course online you know they're having
their guilds or clans and they're
hanging out which is of course very
positive there are so many things I
could talk about as much about the
positive aspects about the other things
of course because I'm a gamer as well
but we have to take a look at what we're
seeing regarding studies and and
research and the fact is that they were
getting hooked so what the gaming
developers are now creating is hooks
based on psychological laws which for
one is is the avoidance of being killed
you know everybody wants to avoid being
killed of course when you're playing
games and they're also been some
research about mice
you know when mice is running in their
wheels and they had like a metal platter
on the ground and when the mines are you
know touching that Mel platter they're
getting this electrical shock but on the
left side they have like a like a steak
and if the mouse is touching that stick
they will avoid having that electrical
shock for three or four seconds so the
mice are learning this avoidance
behavior of not watching this they're
too much not too little just enough to
avoid getting that electrical shot and
this is same thing about video gaming
you know we want to avoid you know
falling down the the ladder that the
ranking system so you're investing
hundreds thousands of hours to becoming
somebody you know having that identity
and then say for instance you have to go
for vacation two weeks so what happens
of course you have be punished you will
have to you know fall down from that
ranking system so that is one of the
hooks and there are many hooks so you
know yeah well I'm glad you mentioned
that there are positives to this too
because in and of itself it doesn't
sound like any of the you know getting a
hit of dopamine is nice
and getting some social community is
nice and all of that so really what
you're talking about is they're adding
hooks which are basically crushing our
ability to have moderation related to
this and that's what it is because I you
know when I did YouTube week here I had
a couple gamers on and I'm and I'm
friends with some gamers and I had a guy
by the name of Skye Williams who's a
youtuber on and he talked a lot about
how he had had some real pain and abuse
in his in his real life and that the
escape of the video game world actually
allowed him to ultimately become a much
better person in the real world so this
is really about moderation and
unfortunately the the developers and
that's a really interesting part that I
didn't know the developers are now using
our own psychology against us of course
I mean there is so much good things
about you know video game games and and
of course you know people that having
autism like AD do a DHD or Asperger you
know they have a tendency to isolate
themselves so that bridge of playing
video games and connecting with people
is such a positive things but then again
it can be overused as well it can be
only that platform which means that
they're you know up all night there are
not you know sleeping they are spending
like 16 18 hours a day and playing video
games because they're so obsessed of
becoming this high ranking you know
gamer and of course moderation is the
key for sure
what about the part of video games that
allows us to get the violence out and I
suspect your answer also will be related
to moderation but you know a game like
that I used to play on the original
PlayStation grand theft auto I never
even played the game to accomplish
anything I'd run around town and I beat
people with the bat and I'd steal cars
and I'd Drive into hordes of people most
of those things I don't do in real life
I don't think video games cause
real-life violence but basically my
point being that I got out some
aggression and then I didn't feel the
need to take it out in the real world do
you buy that general premise I do I do
actually because there is no you know
scientific or studies that actually
shows up
that I mean many people wants to believe
that you know the school massacres and a
lot of these things are gamers and they
were gamers that actually committed that
but there is no you know there is no
connection of that and their studies
showing actually the opposite of you
know people playing you know violence
and the video games are getting lesser
stressed and and and of course I mean in
in our bodies we have this fight and
flight system that we have since the
Stone Age for for sure so when we play
we will have an increase of adrenaline
cortisol which is the same as stress
hormones and of course there is also a
term called you know gamers rage but the
game is raised is not based on the
violent content it's more based off you
know you can manage to level up and you
get frustrated so you throw a you know
controller or whatever so so it's not
based on the violence so actually like
you said I totally agree that there are
many studies that shows that you're not
getting violent or that that you're
releasing instead yeah I think that's
positive so you have to be very you know
observant of when it's over using when
it comes to hours when it comes to
social physical and mental negative
consequences and when those things
appears and they're related to a video
game then of course we need to you know
take a look yeah is happening yeah and I
know that we could spend easily the
whole hour here talking just about video
games and I love the gaming community
and I know I have a lot of audience that
are gamers but I think I just wanted to
address that part about the moderation
part and I think most people kind of
intuitively know that so going back to
your own addiction to this whole thing
in your TED talk you mentioned that it
was your son that sort of woke you up to
how addicted you were is that right yeah
yeah you know because I mean this year
is ten years anniversary of Steve Jobs
multi-touch technology you know it's ten
years since the eye
and the iPhones never and the Android
technology came out so basically this
was maybe maybe six seven years ago you
know I was always on my phone all the
time and my son was playing table tennis
and he was really good and I was at this
tournament and you know he came to the
final and I was sitting you know
supposedly cheering and he was supposed
to meet this this guy and there was two
points for my son to win and suddenly I
felt the vibration in my pockets I
looked up my phone and of course I had a
message on Facebook so I had to take a
look something new something exciting
I'm looking at it and then I hear all
the people cheering and I look up and I
see you know people crowding around my
son to congratulate him because he
actually won the whole tournament
but the sad part is that I didn't even
see it so he saw that so he looked at me
and saw that I was looking at my phone
so these kind of things kind of made me
think about chases what is technology
doing to us and me especially so you
know that was one experience but I had
many so yeah I mean it in a way although
it doesn't sound that traumatic it's
obviously upsetting you know it's sort
of like an alcoholic having their rock
bottom moment you you missed an
important moment in in your son's life
so when you had that moment how quickly
did you try to start doing things to
wean off of some of the technology well
I started using meditation mindfulness
and Vipassana because I I really wanted
to disconnect and also to be more
present in my body because because I
felt that every time I was reading a
book I couldn't concentrate because I
was so used of this scrolling
information I'm bombarded with every
information so when I actually picked up
a book I couldn't focus so you know
eventually I started cutting down and of
course I used technology I have iPhone 7
I love it I think it's positive but but
for me I need time that I can also
disconnect
and you know once a week go out and
leave my phone at the door or not having
my phone in my bedroom or you know
little things like that so I can
actually learn how to relax relax my
nervous system and my brain yeah and
that is what this seems to be all about
now obviously we're doing this on the
Internet so we're not yet we're not
crapping on the internet here right
we're doing this through this magical
thing and yet at the same time you can
see how we become so dependent in that
you know I can I live in LA here I can't
figure out which ways north south east
west anymore because I take lubbers most
places or I look at Google Maps when I'm
driving so I don't even it none of that
stuff matters anymore and that does
disconnect us from something that's very
human right of course I mean we as
humans have a primitive instinct of
having control of our surroundings so
when we then have this device this
mobile phone that gives us this access
of course we are have a tendency to pick
this phone up all the time there studies
showing that we pick up our phone 150 to
300 times per day Wow
and also 25% of every car accidents is
based on a telephone like you cannot
actually drive your car without looking
at your phone 25% so basically these
kind of behaviors are coming more and
more studies are showing you know babies
are having material difficulties you
know they can swipe and find easily a
reward system but they're having a hard
time even speaking and you know grabbing
a pen or a paper so of course new things
are good but it takes 50 generations to
change our DNA so in the future we will
of course adapt to technology because
technology goes in such a rapid pace so
but we as humans has not changed since
the Stone Age we have the same grain we
have the same nervous system we have the
same everything so of course it's
logical we're about to collide because
we can't multitask our brain cannot
divide
their attention because that is what
technology want is it wants us to do is
to be more efficient to do many things
at the same time yeah so is that the
great I already hear that we do all
these things to hopefully become more
efficient have more time to then maybe
spend more time with our families and
all of that stuff and then we spend more
time with our families and then we're
all sitting around I mean you see this
at restaurants all the time you see a
family three kids and two parents and
literally everyone's staring at the
screen and we're not having that human
connection which is far more important
well look I mean it once again we're not
going back we're not going to live in
the woods you know we we of course have
to look forward but I think we have to
be more disciplined I think the thing
about our technology is to look at it as
a digital diet just as food you know we
can't eat food 24 hours a day you know
and it's the same thing with technology
the computers need to reboot they have
to shut down and to you know turn on
again it's the same thing with us we're
humans we have to have that connection I
contact you know learn how to
distinguish body language stuff like
that especially after the young ones
because the brain develops 200 percent
per year until they a until they come to
the age of 5 and it continues to grow
until it comes becomes 25 yes did you
happen to know of any studies they've
done in terms of memory or attention
span related to all of this because one
of the things that I find as an
interviewer I find often that you can
tell when people are losing their train
of thought you know young people that
don't have a medical condition or
anything like that or just in general
when I'm talking to people more and even
myself sometimes if I'm on my phone for
a long time and then I get into a
conversation I do feel like my my memory
is a little screwy or my my ability to
hold the long train of thought or
something like that are there studies on
that yes there are basically what we're
doing now because of the technologies
that we are using the short-term memory
more instead of the law
term memory so based on the information
that we are getting the bombarded
scrolling I mean the attention span of a
millennium kid today is about eight
seconds and a goldfish has attention
span of nine seconds one second more
basically before we had 12 seconds has
become now eight seconds so to get their
attention we have eight seconds to do
that and just look at the school system
it's very very ancient so of course they
were finding schools very bored but
going back to the short-term memory is
that so let's say for instance I have a
paper I have to you know type and and do
and if I get an SMS that will take my
focus so if I want to put that and get
back to my paper is going to take me 24
minutes to get full attention so
basically the multitasking is what is
activating our short-term memory and
it's it's just a myth that we think that
multitasking is something that is
positive I see and I talk to a lot of
kids that thing you know doing for 5,000
times at a time is it's no problem you
know they're Google something they're
having their Facebook their chatting you
know they're doing many things at the
same time but the result in itself is
becoming very bad so if you do four
things you're going to get 25% of the
result because the brain has to divide
their attention if you do two things at
the same time you're going to get 50% if
you do one thing and that thing only
you're gonna get 100% of that result so
yeah you know activate the long term
memory you have to shut down everything
else and just do that and that's what so
so basically what happens is that you're
integrating that information you are
turning that information into knowledge
it will stick if it's short-term memory
you're gonna forget it
[Music]
you